all right Danny is with us in Austin
Texas hi Danny how are you I'm good
thanks for taking my call how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I'm
in a bit of a bad situation with my
mother I'm currently 28 years old and
she helped me take out some student
loans and it was time for me to go to
school we had no savings for my college
and about $19,000 of that is strictly in
her name in the form of Parent PLUS loan
or it was I paid out about half of it
now our original agreement when we took
it out was that she would pay half of
the monthly payment every month and that
happened for one month and tell my
stepdad found out and he didn't like
that very much so she snuck some cash to
be the next month and after that I've
been pretty much on my own paying this
loan Waymon a Parent PLUS loan is not in
your name it's in her name yes sir okay
so have you have you your agreement was
that you were going to pay half and she
was going to pay half and you have
already paid half so it's hers okay her
name I recently did that she received
some inheritance a large sum payout from
my grandparents recently passing and I
had a discussion with her and it did not
go well okay listen listen you are
taking emotional responsibility for
somebody else's crap because your
stepdad is a jerk did I miss something
no sir your mother took out a loan in
your mother's name that your mother is
responsible for morally with the
agreement she made with you and legally
to the bank am I missing something
no sir okay I'm not trying to be mean to
you but she's being mean to you and they
throwing guilt trips at you like they're
like their travel agent for guilt trips
they are and that's that's been my
dilemma this whole time that were done
paying it your husband is exactly right
he's got a backbone so here's how the
conversation goes calling it mom and
stepdad on the phone okay all right do
they live in your area they do about 10
minutes away
great the four of you sit down have a
cup of coffee and it sounds like this
mom we made an agreement you took out a
loan in your name you were responsible
for half I was responsible for half
morally I was responsible for the half
legally not at all but I've paid my half
and so now mom this is your loan that
was our agreement if that upsets you I'm
sorry but I'm holding you to the
agreement you made with your daughter
regarding her education I'm not paying
this it's yours mom have a good evening
stand up and walk out and if they flop
in the floor and foam at the mouth
that's on them it's not your fault
honey you didn't do anything wrong
they've been playing you like a fiddle
your emotions have been torn up your
stomach's been in a knot your throats
been tight for five years over this am I
wrong she's been beating the snot out of
you emotionally with her erratic
behavior and and you're a grown woman
and your husband has said enough and I'm
with your husband I'm on his team your
mom and your stepdad are wrong and
they're out of control with the story
you gave me yes so just be kind but be
very very firm and very clear you don't
have to raise your voice there's no cuss
words involved mom and mom and stepdad I
love you guys and I know you don't
understand this and I know you don't
like it but that really is becoming
at this point the agreement we made was
that you were going to pay half I have
already paid half it's in your name
here's the paperwork I hope it works out
for you the good news is is not your
name and you're not trying to collect
from them it's just just right there in
her lap and if she doesn't pay it
they're gonna call her and it's not your
problem it's not gonna be your problem
it's her problem that's the beauty of
this it's very clean the the downside is
is that it's just gonna be a problem in
the relationship but guess what there's
already a problem in the relationship
yes you're being abused and so I'm gonna
send you a copy of a book called
boundaries by dr. Henry cloud because
your mom and your stepdad don't have any
and you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to help them have some and I will
give you this from experience when you
set boundaries with people who don't
want you to set boundaries who want to
cross over into your yard and have their
dog poop in your yard when they cross
over the boundaries and then you tell
them they can't do that anymore they
have to stay in their own yard and take
care of their own business they get very
angry it's not unusual at all so I do
not expect this to end well on the short
term I think they're going to have a fit
but I'm past caring on your behalf I
agree with your husband he's put up with
us long enough I would not give another
dime to this any if you do you are you
need to see a coach or counselor and get
some help because you've been you've
been messed up by the situation it's
just horrible I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
so hold on and Kelly's gonna pick up and
we're gonna send you a copy of the book
boundaries by dr. Henry clout you'll
actually read the book and go I know
these people yeah yeah it's in there hey
good luck with it kiddo
but please stand your ground you've done
enough you've done your part and then
some and you put up with this
toodle-oo